[Musik]
[Applaus]
schon flüge
[Musik]
auf dem auto bereist
und welche vision verfolgen die vision
von maschinen die zweite ist habe ich
nicht mehr mit lauter büchern
beschäftigen
das kommt noch nicht so gut
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was die produktiv wenn ich das komplett
ohne große regung school mit zwölf mann
zwar nicht mit den später extrem
schlecht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hmm
[Musik]
das konzert zu erholen
für die haie das ist problematisch dass
man auch noch
das abwägen wie es die haare das wäre
das gefühl dass wir bis mit temporär ist
sondern stabil oder wenn ich musik
spiele das ist ein echter 5th
[Musik]
das sind die xxi
das sind die augen sexy
beim namen darf da ist erstaunlich so
luft griff wer schon reich wurde nur
lokal frage und wie heißt die band die
krone holte sich kaffee gmbh will heißen
darf unter sich blieben
[Musik]
die ig bau hatte conti die europa afrika
und noch 34 meldet hat die 72 und ruth k
und das ist nicht bezahlbar und wieder
abstellen dann sind das die straße
fertig
das ist dann irgendwann doch auch meldet
und müssen größere rolle und da bin ich
schön oder abhängige bezahlt habe die
große party mit live elektronik beats
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nördlich der für mich authentisch 2 also
glücklich eigentlich braucht
[Musik]
überbleibsel vom auto york vom wählte
new york künstlerische jona
juli sehr gut vorgetragen ja schön heißt
warum
jubelschreie aus natürlich wir ein
großer teil von new york musik kunst und
zwischen war wo experimentelles
elektronische musik
denn nun muss ich sagen bildende künste
[Musik]
die produktion ist auch schon los musik
drahtlos mit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
telefon und dieses pedal und ich moment
mal ich würde mit einer melone den
bombardiert dann ist es okay das ist
dafür wirklich gute idee und das auf ich
glaube meine rolle in der band ist oft
mit ortungs ideen die umsetzbaren
herauszufiltern
[Musik]
ich mache mit elektronischer musik
sondern ich assimilieren temporäre
ästhetik das heißt ich mache eine
abstraktion vorprogrammierter musik in
realtime für das muss aber wenig spiel
wie es sind alles equipment stand die
neue finde und weiterentwickeln
[Musik]
circle
john stamos new york city store ist fix
ist sie wieder im experiment ein
prototyp kost im moment eigentlich strom
ein effekt züge effekt mechanische züge
statt
[Musik]
im juni kommt er hat einfach immer schon
die signalempfang generiert werde schon
als kind also auch das prozent für die
musik wurde zum schluss amerika der jazz
soul funk rock ich bin mit einer
völligen eklektische europäische vision
[Musik]
was gemerkt dass die 40 jahren spiegeln
das ist grad positive musik max sondern
konservativen musik und außen rückwärts
pro pfund an sich oder besonnenheit
orientiert und ich habe schnell gemerkt
dass ich es aber wählen
[Musik]
vorgemacht hat vor allem wallander
gewachsen
[Musik]
erhöht ist es aber das war nicht das
spieler reagiert löw jetzt ein bisschen
musik oder und sie eigentlich immer
wieder
[Musik]
die version von ostendorf ich glaube
musikwoche wo passiert im moment
[Applaus]
den schritt weg vom theatralische von
präsentieren vom vorspiel wurden nicht
vorspielen musikwoche der intentionen
stadt sondern möglichst gemeinsame
momente erleben ist also mir wirklich
nur das medium sehen das ermöglicht bis
ganz grundsatz von der interessanten ich
bin jetzt aber und sich mit dem moment
unserer zeit sind und der moment der
improvisation ist die zone wo intuition
spiele und
[Musik]
louis
das
er weiß wie man der musik form gibt und
energiekrise das ist etwas ganz anderes
als technik ich kenne nur wenige drama
die das wirklich
der technik ist nur ein werk zurück
viel weiß wie man damit musik macht
nicht nur sport
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stellen eltern wo ich groß sagt mit der
kindheit und jugend verbracht haben
das wiederum nehmen nur als mini suv und
[Musik]
sicher spec über billy higgins wo
maschinen 100 legendären ruf watermelon
man mir kommen sie zur langen schicht
[Musik]
ich glaub eher unison xi wo die bank sie
misst moratorium nicht zwölf stunden
verbrachte fast nonstop oder die
obsession tiefsee oder für möglich
mit mit der normalität wo häufig von mir
verlangt worden ist oder wie möglich wie
auch andere rolle
das eine extreme konflikt ausgelöst und
der nächste schritt ist das refugium
gesehen oder wo ich was sie wieder in
ihrer eigenen welt gebracht haben
[Musik]
80 stunden karte musikschule gaben kaum
ist stunde war unser großes kopiert und
dann versucht die nord spielen oder cpc
computerspiele doch das große tief sei
das ist häufig macht
[Musik]
hier ermöglichen viel zeit verbringe
bewegte städtischen lebens gesehen
[Musik]
er hat natürlich auch der stuhl von
modernen dass man sich später als
lächerlich machen
[Musik]
ich freue mich manchmal müssen wir die
wenigen verboten lecker und von ca
und ich kann toni wegen des mcgraw hill
hatte ich meine persönlichkeit
in london wurde war ein leben in dem sie
emittieren und norma hat und auf die
außen und ich glaube dass jetzt doch zu
spät
[Musik]
bis ganz verrückt sich spüre der schon
körperlich verspielt ich habe ihn sehr
schmal gehört spiele wo ich bin im
vierten monat schwanger bin im club in
capri worden war ich gespielt habe und
ich bin mal ist verstärkt hatte schon
angefangen ist erstmal im buch einen
strampler und erstaunlicher wie möglich
im takt aber du hast jetzt gehabt
da ist doch schön hat das winterpaket
dass mit dem buch von resolute wo nicht
mehr hand im zwölften stock von meiner
20 stöckigen es klappt in hongkong und
teilhabe möglich ein buch vorgestellt
so viele hat
[Musik]
das ist produktion von schweizer
fernsehen mit dem sony fitschen
[Musik]
dass ich noch sie wo sie module mit dem
monty alexander perrig bis 850 pizza
[Musik]
wird als große staugefahr es kommt und
was ist
nachdem wir schon bekommt in ganz europa
ich habe hier ricard an
das streaming hat lässt das mit dem
verdienstorden sich bekommt die bank
forum nichts gründe
das den übrigen sie mit einer halbzeit
erst einmal ohne schlagzeug wenn mit dem
museum damals gewarnt
ich habe es zwar gewohnt abfinden
dass ich die zähne und krokodile sie hat
vorbörslich ich sage nämlich sehr alt
wurde ersatzlos löschen konnte das sagt
viel doch den sehr gefährliche tiere
kaufhofs penis kugeln einer probe aus
einer netto
es steckt natürlich die hinhalte extrem
viele belgier war es ist ganz normal
dass ich damit beschäftigt das ist mir
das passiert
[Musik]
natürlich extrem stellt sich ein gedanke
dass es die reform schafft ich habe das
eine vorgestellte einfach danke
anschlags ist mit ausreden sich nochmal
talent und kann sich das schild wurden
auch die schaffen das schlagzeug aus der
laune meist ab
[Musik]
ich habe relativ wenige lampe wie
champions dann jetzt ganz schlimm aber
sich gottseidank news erhalten obwohl
wir vertreter der it-branche ist kann
aber hey der nation nicht ganz erwachsen
muss immer wieder sind das auch das war
gelebte kritiker haben sich gut ich bin
stolz dass ich das verschiedene kulturen
und in sport in italien glauben
ausgeklappt in der schweiz gehabt und
das ganze nicht alles dokumentiert in
dem haus gefunden wahrscheinlich nicht
befinden hat extrem wenig kunst strom
die
häme drohen gesehen ich habe extreme
intensive kindheit geschlagen
natürlich ist die extrem schwierig
große aufforderungen nicht immer wieder
das problem dass verschiedene vorbei
verschiedene ist möglich wie es gibt das
problem für mich
[Musik]
bitte geh ich in manchester
spiele sehr oft in london und sich
überall hat das problem ein promoter wo
irgendwie das projekt promotet
dinosaurier musik beim projekt
50-jährige musik das problem ist dass
eben auch darum bemüht und mir in den
eigenen reihen besetzen
geschafft aber morgens findet oder den
klub wolfsburg zu koalitionen wo
akzeptabel sind dahin geführt dass ich
muss alles organisieren
[Musik]
beides nicht
oft können nicht schon kritisiert werden
wo kann man sie unterbringen in einem
jazz club rewards georgia wusste genau
wo er spielen wollte kein sitzen das
publikum ihr wollte dass die leute nicht
nur wegen foto meyer kommen sondern
wegen der musik verstehen das nicht wenn
du etwas anderes willst musst du halt
selber machen
john cho ist wahrscheinlich der
innovativste schlagzeuger unserer
generation die sich von einer kunstform
links und hat sein spiel dieser form
angepasst
als er elektronische musik live zu
spielen begann adaptierte jones
einstimmung die syntax dieser musik zu
lernen man könne in der kunst
jahrhunderte zurück gehen
in erinnerung bleiben immer die künstler
die neuland
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und die
was sie
[Musik]
si
doppelt so viel energie
[Musik]
pedro ist ziemlich das gegenteil vom
klischee des neandertalers am schlagzeug
er denkt über die zukunft der kunst der
musik nach
[Musik]
er ist ein großer musiker der mit
integrität und ehrlichkeit sogar geht
und wirklich vertritt wasser
es ist wahnsinn spiele zu sehen es ist
so physisch er schenkt auf die zeit
selbst ein um zu sehen was drin
verborgen ist
foto ist ein meister der zeit streckt
sie er verwandelt sie er verbiegt sie
kreiert live einen zustand der unsere
wahrnehmung von zeit aufzulösen scheint
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele flüge also
verladen
ich muss mich um ist die heimische
baumarten sowie die wohnung erfahrungen
[Musik]
das neue vor dass ich hinter mir war
habe ich mir einfach wohlfühlen am rand
und in zentren
es ist so viel wie in der platte warum
raum davon weil sie wenig dann spielt
die musik und so wenig darüber offen
dort spielt man immer wieder muskulatur
zum neuen musik
[Musik]
das rückspiel für arbeit über die musik
hand auflegen
[Musik]
ich glaube es gibt sehr starke
verbindung zwischen der musik machen mit
dem motto show macht dadurch dass die
industrie sich das schnell voran dass
live entertainment ich konnte besonders
sexy ist dort wie er künstler publikum
interagieren sie völlig neu
das heißt wir sind bei eurosport und neu
zu erfinden
genau das möchte ich das so zu sagen
so sei es entweder extrem gut zu machen
wie sie muss ein bisschen mit welchen
methoden bisher so wurde ich habe mir
schon vorstellen dass das könnte
funktionieren für autistische aber nicht
alles allein machen wo betriebe den
moment reality the world away sich das
vor ihrer sorge macht meinte oder
rutschiger
[Applaus]
so zeigt angebote berührt
[Musik]
innovation ist für mich bedeutet
innovation evolution
[Musik]
studie jetzt freuen wir uns nicht einig
werden chip im kopf hinhalten während
halb digital
wie möglich wieder letzter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die csu so mancher überwertet kreativ
müsse sie mit seinem grund nämlich
kreativ sie werden
[Musik]
als künstler gastraum bessere realität
schon viel besser wie menschlichkeit
schaffen große
ich glaube das wichtigste schnitt wie
was macht und wies auf schlagzeug das
buch schreiben
wichtig ist dass wir neugierig und
voller potenzial forum wo es ihm gar
nicht
[Musik]
für das 1
nein
dieses video
das hatte ich mir über alles ist
geht so
wenn das billing
hinter ihm liegen sie in hongkong sie
wollten geschäfts geworden aber mit zu
kriegen die die allerersten drückt ist
in dieser saison kommen und ich habe das
häufig beobachtung nicht im auto hinten
drin klopp will sie im halbschlaf gebiet
sie das ist total wunderbar und die
sehnsucht nach der wahl der rechtsform
aber break
eine familie mit dem herz stehen
die tauben
auf der anderen
[Musik]